[Music]
so you're a kid growing up in a troubled
household
maybe your parents got divorced maybe
your dad made you feel like you were
never good enough for him
whatever it is your childhood left you
with the feeling that the world
neglected you
that just wait i'm gonna make so much
money and be so successful just to prove
you all wrong
because deep down maybe your success
will finally earn you the respect you
crave from your parents
or maybe you've been gifted with a high
iq you're a super sharp guy but due to
circumstances
you never got your chance to move up the
ladder in the legitimate world
so what do you say i could start
tomorrow or even why not tonight
no
or maybe you're just an ordinary guy
working an ordinary nine-to-five job
that has years of pent-up drinks that
you never pursued
that has also been down on your luck
lately whatever it is you've come to the
conclusion that getting the money and
status you want in the legitimate world
just
isn't for you it's too slow too boring
it's for suckers
[Music]
the rest of us
[Music]
you want to make your millions fast
after all the ones
at the top are far from honest so why
should i be honest
so you come across a few convenient
opportunities where if you
took advantage of said opportunity and
made some quick cash
no one's gonna catch you so you decide
to convince people into giving you their
money
or by profiting off of a loophole you
found for some good old fraud
why because foolishness money are lucky
enough to get together in the first
place
because if you're dumb enough to get
tricked into giving me your money
then that's what you deserve that's the
circle of life because this is what the
world deserves for turning its back on
me
so now you find yourself in a new
exhilarating profession
the profession of being a con man i'm
amazed at what i did
50 years ago is thousands of times
easier to do today
due to technology but if you want to
become a true con
artist not just another scumbag con man
it's going to take some work
so how does this profession work how do
you think like a con
artist how do you best persuade suckers
into parting with their money
let's find out for educational purposes
only
seriously don't calm people and don't
get conned
this could never happen this could no it
nothing's changed yeah there's just way
too much information out there that
today is so
easy to do any of these any of these
things and it's
so ripe for fraud it's like this is true
what's ridiculous
every year by the way millions of
american consumers
seven percent of the population are
victims of some scam or fraud and in
2017 there were 16.7 million victims of
fraud
who lost 16.8 billion dollars
as you're gonna learn a great con artist
is really just a great salesman
a great salesman that uses his sales
skills for bad but here's the thing
sales is one of the most important
skills you need in life no matter what
job or business you're in
want to land a new job you're going to
have to sell your employer on why they
need to hire you
want to get a girlfriend you're going to
have to sell her on why she should
choose you
and as an entrepreneur you're literally
selling all the time
you're selling to your customers your
investors your potential talent
you get the idea so if you want to be
successful in life you're gonna have to
get good at
selling and the book i extremely
recommend for list is the way of the
wolf by none other than jordan belfort
the real wolf of wall street portrayed
by leonardo dicaprio
which is where today's video sponsor
comes in audible a big part of sales is
your tonality
how you modulate your voice for maximum
persuasion
by the time you read about it in the
wall street journal it's already
too late so with audible you can listen
to not only what jordan belfort says in
the way of the wolf
but how he says it which is far more
important and it really epitomizes
one of the advantages of audiobooks i'm
one of those natural born salesmen
who can sell ice to an eskimo oil to an
arab pork to a rabbi or anything else
you can think of
i have been using audible for years and
it has completely changed my life
and with their new audible plus plan you
get full access to their entire plus
catalog filled with thousands upon
thousands of select audio books and more
and now happens to be the best time to
try audible plus because of their
holiday offer
you're getting the best offer of the
year only 4.95 cents a month for your
first six months
and after it's still only 7.95 cents a
month
pause the video right now and visit
audible.com jake tran or text jake tran
to 500 500 to sign up now
the link is on the screen and in the
video description below
someone once said that there's no such
thing as an honest man
he was probably a con man
[Music]
scams come and go what worked yesterday
might not work today
but even though the rackets are
constantly changing the mind of a con
artist the psychology of a criminal
stays the same
the one thing that stays the same no
matter how much technology is in the
world the criminal mind
stays the same thinks the same it's the
same scams that they did 50 years ago
are the same scams today
they're just using another method to do
it so once you know all those scams
you know how they think it's just a
question of figuring out
now how are they doing it but con
artists do come in a few different forms
maybe for you you do it for the thrill
of getting away the perverse pleasure in
screwing someone over
the adrenaline rush you get when you
know that you outsmarted not just your
mark
but law enforcement and society it's a
huge thrill
you feel like james bond the pleasure of
presenting that fake id those documents
and watching your market overwhelmed
with greed
the status you require for your deeds
you walk into the bank and you provide
them with
fake id social security card fake w2's
fake pay stubs and they're calling you
mr black the entire time and then they
cut you a check for 250 000
and you walk out of the bank and they
thank you for being a great customer
and you you that's double 07 stuff i
mean you feel amazing or maybe for you
you're more of the robin hood style con
artist
i'm not stealing from innocent people
i'm counting big banks large greedy
corporations
they're the ones actually screwing
society i'm just giving them what they
deserve no one's gonna get hurt
what's wrong with me making some money
no scruples at all about taking money
from the bank saw it as an institutional
crime i didn't see it as hurting anybody
what i stole i felt like was was a
pittance or maybe you're a true con
artist
one of those highly intelligent types
that doesn't just do it for the money
it's not about the money it's about the
game
the game between people and that's all
it is
you're naturally cunning manipulative
always looking for ways to come out on
top
you like a crime just like how a
mountain climber looks at a peak
it's there someone's got to be
successful at it why not let it be me
but whatever kind of con artist you are
all of them have three things in common
as explained by legendary con artist
frank abagnale
who was also portrayed by leonardo
dicaprio in the movie catch me if you
can
the first trait of a real con artist is
personality which we already went over
the second is observation do you see
things only in black and white like
typical smart
educated people do or do you see things
in the gray
when someone tells you no or i can't do
that do you take that at face value
or do you look for ways to maneuver
around them to manipulate them into
compliance
the third trait of a great comment is
research after all a lot of the time
you're gonna need social security
numbers ids and other intimate data on
people
how resourceful are you in acquiring
that so now that we set your mind right
it's time to pick your rackets
[Music]
in this more ever connected world there
are ever more scams for you to choose
from
why because even though we've advanced
so much today's products
organizations systems and society in
general are still made by honest law
abiding citizens that don't think like
you and i do that don't think like
criminals
most companies are worried about making
money fast they're not going to spend
that extra time and money to make sure
their products can't be broken into
so almost everything in society is right
with exploit points for us to loot
especially in government organizations
that don't involve the military or law
enforcement
they develop these technologies without
ever going to the final step in saying
now
how would someone misuse this and let's
block that from
ever occurring they'd never do that
there are lottery scams irs scams
investment scams romance games charity
scams and many more
when you're thinking about designing
systems that are convenient and useful
very rarely are you also thinking what
would somebody who has
all day to think about how to ruin this
for everyone and steal from it
be be thinking most of the time the most
profitable scams are gonna be the ones
you find in whatever industry you're
already in
you already know the ins and outs you
already know the weak points in the
system
what the little thinking i'm sure you
can figure something out but on the
other hand a lot of great opportunities
come during bubble hysterias
whether that be during the dot-com boom
the real estate bubble bitcoin in 2017
and so on
if you're lucky and you're already in an
industry that's going through a bubble
hysteria
and you've got the right personality get
ready to make millions
no matter what racket you pick every
scam has two red flags
you want to ask the mark for money now
usually in an untraceable way
or you want to ask the mark for personal
intel data birth mother's maiden name
social security number etc so pick your
racket and let's move on to the mark
when it comes to picking your target
it's not a matter of how smart or dumb a
person is
it's more about how easily you can
manipulate their emotions to get them to
trust you
most people in this world are honest
they don't have a deceptive mind they
don't think that evil exists out there
it's completely inconceivable to them
the thought never enters their mind that
the person they're talking to may not be
who they say they are
that they could be getting scammed right
now and if you're sitting there right
now thinking that i would never fall for
any of this
well you make the perfect mark it
sounds to some people okay that's cliche
or it's antiquated it's old i'm never
gonna fall for that
i think people who think that way that's
the type of thinking that makes you a
good victim or a good mark
and you can easily spot these people out
and about by that naive innocent
childlike look on their face
the face of someone who hasn't
integrated their shadow and i've seen
this happen in my clinical clients
when they come in and they're too
agreeable and if you look at people you
can tell
because the people who are too agreeable
look childlike and innocent
but when the person integrates their
shadow and gets the aggressive part of
themselves integrated into their
personality their faces harden
these are the prey you want to targets
once you have your target
now it's time to put the scam into play
picking your attack point is gonna
depend on what kind of racket you're
doing
but in general you're gonna want to find
the weakest link which is probably gonna
be a low-wage worker that isn't gonna
care to double check things
i don't get paid enough to verify this
stuff it's not my responsibility
i'm gonna go ahead and stop you none of
this matters to me
so i don't need the whole song and dance
so now the weak link is
some guy in a call center at a t or
verizon who makes 15 bucks an hour
that's not a weak link that i want with
all of my money attached to it
or it might be someone working on
commission that's incentivized to
overlook certain discrepancies in order
to close the sale
he knows i can get this guy alone is
there a fraud alert yeah
but i can get him alone got it with if i
just overlook that so i'm going to
overlook it because it doesn't make
sense
a lot of the times you're going to need
intel whether that be a security
question like what's your wife's maiden
name to access someone's account or fake
credentials
the great news is that today people post
a lot of the stuff out in the open on
social media
maybe you can call them and claim that
you're with the irs or police
there's been a problem with your taxes
and we just need to confirm your social
security number or
address this type of intel gathering is
called solicitation
or you can post as someone surveying
homeless people and we just need your
social security number
to get an estimate of how many soup
kitchens we need to build
at this point i'm surveying homeless
people i've got a little badge
i know it's horrible i feel bad so stop
judging me for 20 bucks they're filling
out the form
how would you like to make 20 bucks sure
i get a social security issued so i've
got clean social security i got
credit i got a house i got whatever i
want in your name you're some guy that
lives under a bridge in las vegas
the only limit is your creativity
[Music]
while the scam is going on you want to
make sure that you look the parts
the whole just walk in acting like you
belong there may sound cliche
but again we're not trained to question
whether or not a pilot wearing a pilot's
uniform is really a pilot or not
that when i put that pilot's uniform on
no one
questioned that i looked too young to be
a pilot so it was amazing that the
uniform was so powerful people just saw
the uniform that's all they saw
and by the way guys these clips are from
episode 1 of the jordan harbinger show
where jordan interviews that famous con
artist frank abignale that was portrayed
in the movie catch me if you can
really great interview that you can
check out with the link below if your
racket is getting phony mortgages for
example
you want to look clean cut and to have
all your bank statements and such to
back yourself up
that way if any discrepancies come up
like a fraud alert for example
people may brush it off more often than
you think even if it shows up
in the credit profile when they pull it
fraud alert
social security number just issued
issued within the last year
they disregard it right away because
you're sitting there in front of them
and i'm a clean cut
guy and i don't appear to be nervous or
leaving so i have all the right
documents and
if you need to talk to your loan or your
boss or whatever we need to get this
taken care of let's get going
yeah i'm good thanks they just keep
going
like we mentioned earlier the best con
artists are really just amazing salesmen
so you want to use that persuasive
tonality and body language to get them
under your spell this is where frank
epping now calls getting them into the
ether
and there are two ways to get them there
one is by getting them feeling greedy
you want them to fantasize about what
they're gonna get about what they're
gonna do with all that quick cash
to turn off that logical side of their
brain smooth talked them into thinking
that this is a once in a lifetime
opportunity that if i act now i might
double my investment that if i wire the
money this girl will fly over here and
marry me
the other way to get them right for
looting is to get them to feel fear
but hey this is officer jake from the
police department we have your grandson
here in jail
if he doesn't post bond he'll have to
spend the weekend in jail so pay up
the more stress you can get them the
better the thing you have to worry about
is that once you get them under the
ether
it doesn't last forever don't let them
sit on this overnight or else they'll
come to their senses so really instill
that urgency that you have to act now
once you've extracted your well-deserved
money most comment will just run away
the problem with that is that if you
just disappear it will be obvious to
your mark that you scammed them
they might report you to the police
things will get hot but sometimes that's
your only option
optimally you should give them a reason
to leave you alone
for example when former fbi's most
wanted con artist matthew cox got banks
to issue him mortgages under false
identities
when he stopped paying those mortgages
and just kept the money he would send
the bank a convincing police report from
his sister that he got into a horrible
car accident and would never be able to
work again
after all tragedies do happen so he gave
the banks a reason to forget about him
and there you have it just like when a
business starts taking off
once you've duped your first mark it's
gonna be pretty exhilarating addicting
and you want to scale up
good but just know that the biggest
temptation of a criminal is that when
things start to heat up
it's always oh just one more hit just
one more job just one more ruse and i'll
be done
it's over i'm gonna stop now
but it's never just one more you can't
stop
and like i've mentioned before the more
taking you do in a relatively free
society
most of the time the angry mob of the
public will eventually take you down
which brings us to today back in the
days con artists had to go face to face
with the people they were ripping off
so there was a little bit more humanity
empathy involved
you know even in the old days a con man
had a little bit of conscience
about him okay i won't take too much
money from this old man i'll leave him a
little
but today most games are done online
over long distances
and without that face to face human
contact scammers are ruthless
there's no empathy involved kind of like
twitter so unless everyone starts taking
their online security much more
seriously
as technology grows so will the
opportunities to loot
guys these videos take a lot of work to
make so if you want to
support this channel financially so we
can keep pumping out these video essays
for you
don't forget to check out our sponsor
audible i can say with a hundred percent
certainty that starting audible has been
one of the best decisions of my life
the audiobooks that i've listened to and
taken action on has made me a lot more
money back than the few bucks it costs
per month and even though they're
sponsoring this channel i still pay the
monthly fee because it's completely
worthless
the biggest game changer for me with
audible is that listening to audiobooks
takes a lot less mental effort than
reading a book
and the less friction you put between
yourself and the things you have to do
like educating yourself
the more likely you are to do it i am
very proud to have them as a sponsor and
i think they are the perfect sponsor for
this channel and you can get their best
deal of the year for audible plus for
only 4.95
per month for the first six months and
afterwards it goes up to only 7.95 a
month
you get full access to their entire plus
catalog filled with thousands upon
thousands of bucks and more
and five to eight dollars per month that
could potentially change your life is a
pretty good roi in my opinion
so visit audible.com jaketrade or text
jake trent to 500 500 to sign up now
as you can see we have a badass new
backdrop behind us
that i spent way too much time trying to
align and is still not aligned correctly
and if you want to know why i chose
these specific individuals these
incredible thinkers and doers behind me
and the whole philosophy behind the
setup
well you're just gonna have to follow me
on instagram and view the latest posts
because this is the perfect opportunity
to funnel you guys over there
jaytrend.io link below
again shout out to my friend jordan for
the amazing podcast and of course
valuetainment who has the best
interviews on youtube in my opinion
that is gonna wrap it up for this video
thank you so much for watching you've
been awesome i've been jake stay
dangerous out there
and i'll see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you